[Musique]
encore plus difficile de gérer des
hommes c'est le gérer des dirigeants on
a tous vu à travers le monde les députés
qui faisait la boxe dans l'assemblée
nationale c'est ce travail que moi je
fais je coach je forme et je dirige les
jeunes les plus prometteurs de ce
continent
les jeunes qui ont envie de changer le
futur et ce continent et c'est toujours
difficile de pouvoir les inspirer parce
qu'ils sont déjà des leaders ils sont
déjà des gagnants ce sont des gens qui
ont traversé des choses difficiles dans
leur vie ils ont eu des rêves
ils les ont réalisés ils sont considérés
comme des modèles dans la société
donc ils ont déjà réussi pour un il
suffit pas le apporte quelque chose il
suffit juste de le rappeler le rappeler
qu'ils sont le rappeler pourquoi ils
sont là et une chose que j'ai apprise à
travers avec les leaders à travers tout
le continent
c'est que les leaders n'aime pas les
chèques un leader n'échoue pas et puis
vient à la maison
oh j'ai joué aujourd'hui c'était la plus
belle chose qui m'est arrivé
jamin un leader quand il échoue is
enough
il est frustré elle est annulée elle est
énervée elle a envie de réussir
mais comment arriver à donner ce même
esprit à toute la société
la société nigérienne la société
guinéenne
la société burundaise rwandaise
nigériane celle de l'afrique du sud
celle du mal à l'aise car on doit
pouvoir les apprendre à gagner si on
veut avoir des gens dans notre
entreprise dans notre communauté dans
notre famille et on veut qu'ils gagnent
faut qu'on leur réponde l'accueil faut
que l'on apprenne à penser comme des
gagnants est aujourd'hui d'ici la fin de
ce toc
chacun d'entre vous ici pourra gagner et
vous allez sortir d'ici et vous allez
aider des hôtes à gagner vous êtes prêts
vous êtes prêts super donc du coup pour
gagner une toute petite et toute cette
formule elle s'appelle le rue de la
résilience
disons le non c'est pas influence hockey
génial pour réussi en afrique surtout en
afrique surtout dans les pays pauvres
est difficile d'afrique
il faut avoir du cran mais c'est quoi
leur
on va le découvrir peu importe qui vous
êtes
peu importe d'où vous venez peu importe
votre background si vous appliquez ces 3
vous allez réussir la première des
choses c'est la raison de vivre
la deuxième des choses ce sont les rêves
et la troisième c'est la réalité
mais comme je vous ai dit le but c'est
pas que vous parce que vous vous êtes
peut-être des leaders vous avez déjà
gagné donc tout ce que je ferai ça vous
rappelle quelque chose que vous
connaissez déjà mais il ya d'autres
personnes qui sont fatigués de perdre
ils sont toujours en train de perdre ils
ne comprennent pas pourquoi ils perdent
c'est pas qu'ils sont pas plus
intelligents
c'est pas qu'ils n'ont pas le potentiel
mais c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas encore
appris à gagner donc on va les apprendre
à guin et l'objectif à la fin de cette
de cette discussion soit que chacun de
vous partez et et d un million de
personnes à gagner un million chacun
d'entre vous deux personnes à gagner
avant que vous vous retirer on continue
raison de vivre il ya deux questions au
connaître pourquoi nous vivons pour qui
je me bats pourquoi je me bats pour qui
je veux réussir
pourquoi est-ce que je veux réussir pour
qui j'ai envie de gagner
pourquoi j'ai envie de gagner j'ai envie
de réussir pour mes enfants je veux que
mes enfants aient un bon modèle qui peut
suivre
j'ai envie de réussir pour mon pays je
voudrais que mon pays change
j'ai envie de changer la façon dont les
ordures sont gérés dans ma ville c'est
une raison c'est une raison de vivre
c'est ce qui fait la différence entre
les vidéos qu'ils gagnent et les autres
et les doigts qui gagneront toujours
quelqu'un pour qu'ils se battent ils ont
toujours une cause le grain que même
pour laquelle il se bat à tout moment
donc ça c'était là là
la jeune mia la deuxième chose
les rêves on ne peut rien réaliser dans
la vie c'est un rêve
on dit même un homme c'est un rêve une
forme c'est un rêve vie pourtant ils
sont morts parce qu'ils n'aspirent
apurée et n'ont plus envie de découvrir
de changer ou de réaliser quoi que ce
soit mais la question qu'on se pose
lorsqu'on veut atteindre ses rêves ses
je veux je désire j'ai envie je veux
changer les choses dans ma communauté
je veux une mère maison je vais me en
vie pour mes enfants je veux aller à une
meilleure école je désire voyager à
travers le monde
j'aspire à devenir président
ce sont des rêves ça ses rêves vous
pouvez rien faire de nouveau parce que
vous allez rester dans votre zone de
confort comment nous faire dans le télex
vous ne pouvez pas sortir parce que vous
avez peur alors que votre rêve est là
ils font rêver
il faut encourager les gens à rêver et
c'est là où la différence cela on trouve
la différence entre les gens qui
réussissent et ceux qui échouent entre
les gens qui réalisent continuellement
le rêve et les autres qui s'arrête en
cours de route c'est la réalité ce qui
lève et n'arrive pas à mettre le rêve
dans la réalité et je suis toujours
pourquoi parce qu'ils connaissent pas la
réalité mais que l'on connaît de ces
réalités question très simple
quelles sont mes aptitudes quelles sont
mes forces
quelles sont mes faiblesses quelles sont
les opportunités qui existent dans mon
environnement
quelles sont les qualités humaines que
j'ai que bien sûr l'autre dans ma
famille non et que je peux apporter à la
société
la deuxième question c'est quelles sont
les obstacles à mon rêve
quelles sont les difficultés pour
réaliser mon rêve quels sont les
challenges que doit-on rencontrés
lorsqu'ils voulaient réaliser le même
rêve lorsque vous êtes conscient de ces
réalités qui existent dans votre
environnement vous poser la question
comment utiliser mes forces
et les opportunités de mon environnement
afin de réaliser mon rêve
vous vous le faites peut-être de façon
inconsciente
vous l'avez fait tellement de fois que
vous pensez que c'est naturel et vous
vous dites non j'ai toujours été comme
ça non vous n'avez pas toujours été
comme ça vous avez appris vous avez osé
vous avez pris l'initiative pour devenir
ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
mais si vous ne bâtisse est pas toute
une nation de gens qui peut faire mieux
que vous quel sera le futur de notre
continent
alors donc aujourd'hui j'aimerais que
chacun nous quitte ici avec un rein un
sens heureux je ne serais pas là
aujourd'hui
ma grand mère a dit à ma mère une fois
élu ton fils elle à l'université pour
apprendre à échouer il échoue trop ce
petit là il à l'université de médecine à
la faculté de mathilde a échoué hélas la
faculté d'ingénierie il a échoué
et là elle a la faculté d affaires est
dit vous êtes un homme d'affaires il a
échoué
on peut rien faire de lui pourtant
j'étais un rêveur et j'ai dit un jour en
guinée je lis j'ai créé le premier site
agro touristique du pays on m'a dit
c'est impossible
tout le monde a une ferme ou une
plantation mais personne ne va visiter
sa propre plantation
pourquoi les gens iront chez toi je leur
ai dit j arriverai j'ai vendu mon rêve
en mon équipe je l'aï bâtissant ce site
d'une façon que le président a au public
puisse venir
le président a plu n'est pas venu mais
les gens sont venus de quarante
différentes nationalités à travers le
monde pour venir découvrir
l'ambassadeur des états unis est venu
découvrir
l'ambassadeur la grande bretagne est
venu découvrir et les gens ont commencé
à dire il est fou et mes petites nuances
et les blancs c'est les plans c'est les
plans petit c'est les blancs qui voyait
sa foule il a géré un autre rêve
lorsqu'on a eu la crise des mollahs et
qu'il n'y avait plus de touristes et que
le secteur agricole et tech était bloqué
je me suis déjà je peux transformer ce
centre a un sens de paix
je me suis dit à mes gars besoin ces
pays on a besoin de former les jeunes
donc je les transforme en un centre de
formation ago entreprenariale mais
j'avais un plus grand rêve je disais
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de personnes
comme moi qui n'arrive pas à réaliser
leurs rêves à travers le monde donc il
faudrait que je puisse partager mon
espoir avec eux il faut bien que je
puisse le informé de ce que j'ai vécu
les esprits a aussi réalisé le rêve j'ai
eu un rêve j'ai un rêve que j'étais sur
la couverture d'un magazine avec le
président barack obama derrière moi et
qu'il avait sa main sur mon épaule et
voilà vous et ils ont ils encore c'est
un rêveur ce jeune là il ne fait que
rêver disait ma mère il faudrait que tu
lui parles 1 parce qu'on ne sait pas ce
que lui va devenir mais j'ai cru en mon
rêve et je regardais autour de moi je
regardais les problèmes qui existaient
les jeunes avaient besoin d'inspiration
la communauté avait besoin d'être
motivés donc j'ai créé une émission
radio pour les jeunes j'ai sponsoriser
une équipe de basket
j'ai créé des programmes de formation on
a créé le premier mouvement
d'entrepreneuriat social en guinée et
j'ai été sélectionné pour le mandela
washington fait de chair et dans une
salle comme ça j'étais arrêté et le
président barack obama était entendu
parler le lendemain
michelle obama était en train de parler
et lorsqu'elle passait elle est venue
juste devant moi et m'a tendu la main
elle a mis sa main sur mon épaule
c'est là je me suis dit les rêves ne se
réalisent pas de la façon dont elle veut
mais il se réalise donc du coup ce soir
aujourd'hui changeant le monde ce soit
aujourd'hui
changeons le niger ce soir aujourd'hui
changeant le destin de l'afrique avec
l'euro merci
[Applaudissements]